I can't believe what we just saw winning
the bid by one second and this just
shows how well the two players know each
other we've got liftoff uh I'm a bit
shocked I'm a bit gobsmacked having less
than nine minutes against Hikaru
Nakamura having a six minute deficit and
the black pieces it's not gonna be easy
it is Magnus of course but I think we'll
see some serious flagging if Hikaru
can't win on the position which is quite
likely quite possible Hikaru has to win
on demand he's got the white pieces he's
up on the clock by a big margin Magnus
Carlson needs just to draw and the
moment you say that sentence is kind of
it's hard to believe it's hard to
believe that you can fight this a dirty
Flagger he wants to win on the clock not
on the board I mean you look at the
position black has everything under
control what Hikaru is relying on his
lead on the clock he just wants to keep
the position as ambiguous as possible
yep no trades no exchanges no
clarification of the position he's just
trying to force Magnus to go into the
tank at some point which is guaranteed
to happen and only later maybe put him
under pressure on the board or make him
uh kind of force him into those
difficult decisions with the white piece
and it wasn't just that it was also hit
card knock more flagging the bots on ICC
because he would close the position and
make a million moves then upon move and
things like that to beat the boss on the
internet chess club so here in this game
uh he's not a bot he's only human but he
plays like a bomb most time Magus
Carlson only eight minutes on the clock
no piece have been traded yeah no blogs
have been traded as well so super closed
position here when you're in the
Armageddon when you're up on the clock
you've got to play the clock as much as
the position and look at Hikaru this is
when he's going to make Magnus thing
Harry the H Pawn goes up the board G4
coming in next you can also activate
there we go on a nicer diagonal now for
Hikaru he knows these inside these ideas
inside out he's been playing these ideas
since he was a kid yes with reverse
colors normally he's on the black side
but it's the exact same Pawn structure
is increasing if anything in hikaru's
favor this is really worrying times for
Magnus I've got to say if we get King
and Rook vs king and Rook which is an
obvious draw Hikaru Nakamura will try to
flag him so Magnus he needs to keep his
eye on the clock he can just play
quickly every single turn and David
you've been talking about that white
Bishop on H3 one plan that black has to
follow up with the trades would be to
move the queen ahead and then to defend
that Bishop coming to E6 but look at
this the position has blown open hikao
says now is the time I try I strike in
the center F4 that is one committal
decision by Hikaru finally there is a
trade finally Black's drop here or at
least the next few moves have become
clearer they have become more obvious
and yes the evaluation bar shoots up on
white side but he needs to back it up on
the board now Hikaru can't just rely on
the clock and realign his Rooks but it's
not the king that uses the corner it's
the Knight what a flexible move
everything bring up an analysis where I
think there was a pretty critical moment
here for Hikaru he decides to step
backwards but I think he could have
sacrificed the pawn going E5 and after
Pawn takes Pawn F5 this is a thematic
Pawn sacrifice you throw your knight to
E4 you control all of the squares in the
position and you have an attack I don't
know if it would have worked out it does
involve sacrifices and material but a
current set drops is my back top four of
a longer game it just feels like it's
easier to play with why the moves that
you're suggesting are appearing on the
board David he takes the queen out
expecting the bishop to come out the
Rook to come out to a better square and
at some point Hikaru will strike down
the board with H5 because you really
don't want to trade the bishop for the
night he just first sidesteps with that
King to H1 really hinting at that move
H5 right now which will make Magnus go
into a bit of a think because he needs
to be prepared to respond with that
Magnus immediately plays the move Bishop
E6 we've been talking about the
importance of trade in this position he
is afraid of the attack a little bit the
best way to respond to that to this is
to trade off your opponent's pieces
playing this uh F sorry this F5 break
will become very relevant black can open
it on his own terms but uh let's go back
Tanya you predicted the future this time
and uh this is the current position F5
on the board trying to open up lines for
Black's pieces David I love Black's
position we've been talking about how
ideally the Rooks are placed and take a
look at this now after F5 I don't see a
way in which white can actually open the
center that looks like it would be great
for black if Hikaru decides to trade you
take it with the pawn the G file is open
the queen can swing from C7 to G7 at the
right time you can double up on the
e-file it looks like white might have to
make the decision to push that e-pawn
and he does it it's E5 the bishop on E7
and now this H4 weakness suddenly
appears out of nowhere yeah uh he's at
least hinting that he might trade off
these set of Pawns now and uh maybe
shift the white Rook across towards that
black king still enough pieces left to
create an attack for Hikaru Nakamura but
he needs to do it quickly now he needs
to rely on his Instinct stop being in
your own head stop calculating you just
got to go for it then hey cargo play for
her that is why Magnus took this Pawn on
H5 that is huge decision by him because
it opens up his own King but look at the
white king in the corner now that's
exposed there's a rook on E6 ready to
slide over to the H6 Square If That
Knight captures on H5 you may lose that
piece if it gets pinned so black can
start taking control of the G and H
files and that's why Hikaru says no no
no no you can keep that pawn there sort
of an umbrella for my king I'm bringing
the Rook to the G file first I want to
play Rook G2 Rook A1 to G1 maybe bring a
rook to H2 as well break all the pieces
to the party before you start taking a
pawn that is double and isolated
question to Magnus how do you
consolidate how do you set up a
defensive wall the black king white
trucks are coming for it and uh okay he
chooses to slide his Rook across all of
them are weak currently black was a pawn
up I was gonna say is
a big blunder yes because there's a
tactic I mean I would not have seen it
without the evaluation where when Knight
takes Pawn on E5 that is a game changer
because once the pawn takes the Knight
on the Square the queen slides up one
with check and then the Rook slides from
G6 to no matter what white does he's
going to lose his Queen so if Magnus
Carlsen spots Knight takes E5 it turns
the tides in his favor and I think he's
looking at the way he's looking at this
position and he's kind of in a little
bit of disbelief Knight takes E5 as a
huge oversight by car Nakamura oh he
doesn't find it he moves his Knight away
same threat but it would have been more
effective to catch report in the process
he would have been winning on the spot
another missed opportunity not the first
time we've said that today by Magnus
Carlson he brings his Knight the other
way so this threat is still on uh on the
cards Queen check followed by The Rook
shifting Hikaru still needs to defend
tenaciously to avoid that one but uh wow
there's missing shots again maybe he's
realized he dodged a bullet there but uh
isn't Black's F5 Pawn hanging random
question it is well I can go and take
that pawn okay he doesn't Hikaru
Nakamura is stepping back that move
shows uh that he really is nervous he
does allow black to grab a pawn now
Magnus support up it's a little bit deep
but I think he didn't take the pawn of
five there might have been a draw by
repetition and had he done that I don't
know if we have time to show it but
that's probably why he took a step back
he knows objectively maybe it's not the
right choice but he needs to win this
game and uh often in Armageddon chess
let's show that Robert just while we
were there Knight takes porn you can
bully your opponent with the thoughts of
a repetition uh how do we get there we
give a check I guess and then sacrifice
The Rook on F5 and then go Rook H6 check
and that's King on H2 is In Harm's Way
it can only go up to G3 in the position
and ideas with Bishop H4 check or Rook
G6 uh maybe I guess that was the wrong
one but the problem is this white king
is in huge danger Magnus missing Knight
E5 and now just wondering if this was
part of the bigger plan that he knew
that Knight F5 he had calculated his way
through knowing that it ends in a
repetition he ends up with an extra
point and while we've got a lot of
Trades that have happened that cannot be
good news for Hikaru can't be good news
the Queens are off the board as well
things are disappearing there is a one
minute difference in it right now but
Magnus should be able to Hoover afford
the pieces did see him react though
maybe realizing he has missed an
opportunity in this game but he only
needs a draw Magnus to win the match
he's now two pawns up but he has let the
white rook in that white Rook is active
now on the seventh rank is going to
start gobbling up some pawns Magnus has
he lost control suddenly Hikaru he's
hustling he's just trying to pose
difficult questions to his opponent if
you can't go and take that black a pawn
maybe push the white a pawn just hint
that you're going to promote it later
okay we see a trade of knights getting
rid of the very strong black knight but
every piece that disappears from the
board every trade guides Magnus closer
to that draw he's still two pawns up
remember and the evaluation bar still in
the middle can Magnus guide this one to
safety still big questions to be
answered okay he does put his Pawn on a
safe square but it's not going to be
safe for too long White's Rook will go
after it eventually there we go and uh
what do you guys think predictions now
under pressure and expectation everyone
chokes but these guys are really
bringing their A-game Hikaru making
decisions that keeps the game going and
that's the key to this Armageddon look
at him just pursuing that pawn Marcus
moves it one more step ahead and now the
bishop comes back to attack it and I
think he's making he's creating his
chances if that a passer is on the board
it's game on like mags has to be nervous
given the circumstances guys we've got
to mention the whole day magnus's air
quality has been great but as the
pressure has increased his air quality
has got worse and worse and worse and
that might be affecting his play and uh
look at that suddenly no green circles
there for him if he goes down to defeat
maybe that would have been one of the
reasons meanwhile a set of Rooks have
been traded and uh Black's pawns are all
weak they're right for the picking
Magnus he's just been playing too slowly
right now if he had better air quality
Maybe he would be a bit faster and every
second counts at this level the margins
are so small but I think that black has
an idea of his own Max will slide his
Rook one square over to d8 use the king
to protect the bishop and then bring his
Rook d8 to D4 and go after the C Pawn we
did see Magnus just bring his Rook to
date after his car stole a pawn so
magnus's plan is now clear will he have
enough time to execute it that's the
essential question but two plus minutes
on this clock I do think it's looking
like a task that he is capable of
handling yeah two minutes so on the
board he's fine but is the clock gonna
tell the decisive Factor here I think
you can jump in there we go the
BlackRock has landed not just as this
brought up for grabs the pawn behind it
and white has to bank everything on this
past Pawn you have to run it through
somehow you have to break the blockade
somehow evict this black Bishop kick it
away and somehow cause some problems for
the black king but on the board it
definitely looks like Magnus is in full
control and uh here we go position
progressing white Bishop is actually the
one being kicked around like his two
connected past pawns Hikaru doesn't look
happy at all and the clock is about even
so hit card doesn't even have his lead
on the clock he's down material that is
terrible news for someone who needs to
win this game yeah he needs to win it
but actually he should be the one
defending look at the evaluation bar
dropping down in Black's favor those are
two Runners those two black pawns
they're gonna cost white some material
and there's no stopping them and we see
Hikaru that he is worried about his
position but he's still wow what just
happened things are turning again this
will happen a lot throughout this time
scramble but the black pawns are running
they look quicker to normally run slower
than one but those two connected plus
pawns are so close to becoming Queens
well I can give a check and move his own
Pawn one square closer to the queening
uh point at it but blackstroke just
saves it and you've got these two pawns
which are unstoppable how do you fight
these two Central pawns devastated
Hikaru looks like he's actually ready to
resign almost all you'd need to do is
Magnus steps and pawns for it you if you
don't get flagged you're guaranteed to
win this Armageddon and now we have kind
of a blitzed game where it's about even
on the clock and Magnus only needs a
draw and we saw the bar go about level
but I think the reason that it wasn't
actually equals because a draw is bad
for a car it might have been a forced
draw and he can't have any part of that
yeah his car is simply a pawn down now
neither of those pawns became Queens but
it did come at the cost of more trades
more exchanges and look at this classy
move from Magnus he's just trying to
swap things off he's now managed to get
rid of the Bishops rid of a set of Pawns
and Hikaru is he gonna try and flag
Magnus the answer is no it's a draw
Magnus takes this Armageddon and the
match and believe that Hikaru is
actually the one who offered a draw
that's the ultimate sign of respect he
wasn't going to try to flag somebody he
was 10 seconds behind on the clock
against that is a good show of
sportsmanship wow we see a big smile on
Magnus Carlson's face and the car
shaking his head the big match is over
Magnus Carlsen wins the winner finals